in wintry Beijing the pace of life is
picking up
people are enjoying being outdoors after
weeks of staying inside after a
widespread covid-19 outbreak
sells traditional sweets from his cot he
welcomed the lifting of restrictions in
December
it's good they've ended all the
restrictions everyone can come out now
it's good for the country if you are
always in lockdown you have no income he
says business is better now than it's
been in years the 67 year old had
covid-19 last month many of the people
we spoke to in this neighborhood have
told us they also caught the virus at
least the 70 to 80 percent of people in
this area got covered well after another
real got sick
for those who have recovered life has
returned to normal tests and health card
scans are no longer required to enter
restaurants and public spaces
Tuesday is the first working day of 2023
and the streets here are busier than
they've been in months many businesses
have reopened and most workers have
returned to the office
but it's not just the streets that are
crowded hospitals are full of people
seeking treatment for covert 19.
the Chinese Center for Disease Control
and prevention says less than half a
million people have been infected
Nationwide but scientists say cases are
dramatically under-reported
the government insists the situation is
under control
Nationwide our medical resources have
not yet reached the situation of tight
Supply we have anticipated a substantial
increase in demand so we are well
prepared
for those who are healthy there's relief
that the years of lockdowns are behind
them and many are looking forward to a
new sense of normalcy
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing